hello welcome back to material for me
master strategy guide today's episode 3
and we're gonna talk about strategy so
these are some of the strongest
strategies at least in my opinion so
here are the stuff we're gonna look at
today so we got the major strategy the
overall game plan I'll talk about that
in a second and then we're going to
release minor strategies and to be
honest the only reason I call these
minor strategies is just to imply that
you can have more of these at once so
when I say the overall game plan or the
major strategy what I mean is this
aspect we talked about in episode one do
I want to aim for a long game or do I
want to aim for a short tier heavy game
basically we have these four scenarios
every single game of terraform mass is
going to shape out to one of these
scenarios number one you got the greedy
engine so you want game to drag out
number two your opponent got the greedy
engine so who wants to close the game to
actually punish the greedy players
number three you try to outgreach your
greedy opponent also entirely reasonable
sometimes this will work out fine and
number four all players are trying to
end the game as soon as possible at this
almost never happens it's so boring man
so in every single game you have to try
to figure out is it in your best
interest to let the game drag out or do
you have a better chance of winning by
being this filthy dirty terraformer
we're gonna get back to that but then we
should look at some of the minor
strategies as well and like I said the
lack of better words such as call these
minor strategies implying that you can
use more of these at once in a given
game you can mix and match these
strategies however you want to the only
strategy that doesn't really mix that
well with the others are the
terraforming strategy and that makes
sense right because the terraforming
strategy really wants to close the game
as soon as possible and most of the
other strategies we're going to talk
about today are gonna be aimed at long
games I've actually attempted to make
this aspect a little bit clearer by
labeling the minor strategies in the
short game or long game in terms of
generation as I feel in most games not
always but in most games some strategies
are more suited for shorter games
whereas other strategies are more suited
for longer games so hopefully in this
way it's like intuitive which strategy
it goes well together and which strategy
does not go well together so minor
strategy number one refuse to terraform
perhaps even to the point where you hold
on to your eat and your plants so this
is aiming for the long game so
especially in two or three player games
there is this annoying strategy where
player just never plays terraforming
cards or he's even holding on to planes
and heat just because that player has
the biggest engine and he wants the game
to drag out it it's really annoying and
then when he feels certain that this is
indeed the last generation no matter
what it does then he just spins all of
his stuff all of his plans always see it
he's been holding on to the thing is all
of the greedy strategies actually want
the game to go for as long as possible
because they make the most VP in the
last iteration and then if you let it go
one more generation they're gonna make
even more VP than you in the last new
last generation so this is why it could
be useful sometimes to hold on to either
your plants or your heat what I mean is
getting plus one generation can make a
huge difference if for example you're
the one going god mode it can really
make a difference because the guy who's
going god mode he's gonna make so many
VP in the last generation it didn't say
as a side note you can also stack up
your heat to claim the water bonus on
the oxygen scale it's actually pretty
common that people do this this bonus is
really important so this is a way of
fighting for that bonus however holding
on to plans and heat could also mean
that you in the end miss out on some TR
which can also be a big deal so you have
to like weigh the pros and cons here
what I mean is if you're holding on to a
lot of plans ahead and then the
parameter is going to close and you're
just you just didn't even notice or
something and then you just sit with
like a thousand heat and you can't use
it for anything it's not good what you
really should do is you should identify
the last parameters to close and then
you're gonna not terraform that too much
if that makes sense so if you recognize
that the heat is the last one to close
then you can hold on to your heat
resources and worth noting here if you
intend to hold back plans you probably
should have protected habitat and I'm
gonna show you a clip of boneless
telling you how many plants he has I
mean look at this I have 60 plants 20
plan production and 60 plans and I
haven't even played insects yet I know
that I wanted to close it at 14 so when
he passes I'm gonna terraform
like until there's like one spot left or
something if that makes sense so just it
just barely goes to 14 Generations
because then I have getting the maximum
out of the tour from rating as well 32
plane production let's go
that's a lot of plans in this game I
went for an Omega greedy car strategy so
in this case it makes like a lot of
sense to let the game drag out if you
want to watch the whole game you can
check out episode 16 part 2. we are
going to talk more about the real cast
reality later in this video minor
strategy number three but before we do
that let's talk about the polar opposite
strategy which is the filthy dirty
terraformer so this is obviously best
for short games so this is where you
just terraform like an absolute madman
and try to end the game as soon as
possible and funny enough even though
the strategy is the exact opposite of
the first one it's equally as annoying
like if you're having a good game a
greedy game and then this guy is just
terraforming it's so annoying the one
the long game you want to have fun right
so why so the idea here is you try to
close the game as soon as possible
because then the guy with the really
greedy big engine he doesn't have time
enough to actually make the transition
from engine building to VP grabbing so
the waves gonna ship out is you're gonna
be ahead in the first half of the game
hopefully the entire game because you
just keep making Tia and keep trying to
close the game so you can see it like
this that if you're the terraforming guy
your VP is going to be like in a
straight line because you're just
starting the game trying to get VP and
by the end you still want to get VP so
that's a straight line whereas the
greedy guy he's gonna have no VP to
begin with because he's making engine
and then in the last year generation
he's gonna Crush you if you let the game
drag on too long but the point is you
want to end the game like like here
before the greedy guy like overtakes you
in the end I hope this is not mirrored
I'm not sure now it's important to
understand that you still need a little
bit of money income yourself you still
play the mega credit cards you get in
the early game you still have to climb
out of the hole like we talked about but
in addition to money and come in the
early game you also value TR our plan
production heat production and then you
can like make a transition from engine
building to tr pretty early on and while
this strategy is pretty boring not gonna
lie it can be quite powerful it's a good
way to punish the greedy guy who
invested so much into a ton of Mega
credit production and card draw so if
you see your opponent getting like 40mb
the production more than you then this
is definitely a strategy you just have
to consider I think only a few times I
actually started the game immediately
thinking okay I'm gonna go all in for
the terraforming strategy I did it on
the master just so I could show you guys
a game where I went for the strategy so
here is the starting hand I had in that
game if you want to see the whole game
it's in episode 17 I'm not gonna lie
this this hand is pretty terrible but I
really didn't get much engine building
cards in my hand so I think I did the
correct thing it just went for the
terraforming strategy it is a little bit
questionable to keep insulation in my
opening hand but this was a three player
game so I just wanted the option
available to me that I could turn all
the heat in to make a greater production
and go for the really long game so this
is also something I considered but I
think in the name of science I still
just went for the terraforming strategy
here I want to point out that winning a
game with this trash Society support is
actually an achievement in and of itself
I really want to make myself clear here
I I I truly I deeply I hate this Prelude
Society support here's some other
examples of Corporations and cards you
might want to pick up when you're going
for the strategy these are just examples
but you can imagine heat production
plant production naturally stuff like
this is what you're looking for and the
funny thing is that even if you are
running this terraforming strategy even
though you're all in and just trying to
end the game even in this case I still
feel like regulate eaters and ghg
production bacteria are still sort of at
cats I'm really not a fan of these cards
however if you do happen to get extreme
cold funkers combined with one of these
cards then it's great of course one free
TR every generation is actually worth
something it's like worth eight Mega
credit production if you want to look at
it that way at least until the parameter
closes and then it's once again pretty
useless also here production is of
course pretty nice when you're going
through this combo so especially to keep
your eye out for some of these heat
combos like we talked about in the first
video so you could decide to play the
terraforming strategy based on your
starting hand like I did here I mean
sometimes you have a starting hand it's
like it's the only thing you have right
and you have to play the cards you're
getting but to be honest most what I do
is I Look to get the greedy engine up
and running and if I have just no luck
building an engine as strong as my
opponent then I will consider to
transition into the strategy instead
also what I sometimes do is I try to
compete with a greedy guy I try to be
greedy myself and if I feel like I'm
Omega losing this war and I'm back to
two cards and he has like 20 cards then
I can look to transition into the
terraforming strategy and try to close
the game as soon as possible so this is
also an idea I think you should always
have this strategy in the back of your
head and finally you should also keep in
mind that the terraforming strategy is
simply better in four or five player
games in two player games the card
strategy is simply Superior I'm gonna go
out on a limb here and say you should
never play the terraforming strategy in
a two-player game three player games
even questionable in two player games
the best strategy is by far the greedy
cast strategy so let's talk about it I
love this one full grid integral chord
mode and this is of course better for
long games the card strategy is the best
strategy for long greedy games and it is
the best strategy for two player games
for the same reason two play games also
usually longer and greedier like we
mentioned in tip 8.5 if there are only
two or three players you should really
aim to play the greedy card strategy
every single game and then you figure no
luck you can make a new plan but just
really start the game out trying to do
this the greedycast strategy can also
work in four to five player games but
then it comes with a lot more risk
because four to five play games tends to
be shorter in terms of generations in
other words the other strategies have a
higher chance of beating you if we're
talking about the four to five player
games so what defines the ultra greedy
card strategy you might be thinking
boneless excuse me I actually do do this
every time I always go for engine and
cards of course so why is this like a
strategy isn't it just what you always
do and not exactly it is true that what
I mostly do is I try to go for money
income and card draw but to go all in on
this particular strategy is a little bit
different here's what I mean number one
you keep all of the card Pro cards even
some of the bad ones you also probably
keep the only way you don't keep outdoor
cards but this strategy is if you just
have too many cards and too little
engine then maybe you just don't keep
all of them so all of the camera cards
are good when you play the strategy
however I don't know I would like to
briefly mention some of the absolute
MVPs I'm talking about the cards where
you draw a card when X happens the thing
is when you play the strategy you want
to be playing like a million cards and
if you're playing a million cards
naturally you're gonna see more Science
Tech you're gonna see more cards that
cost 20 plus which means that these
cards for example are especially juicy
I'm talking Mars University Olympus
conference spin-off Department I don't
think I've ever had a bad game where I
had Master University and Olympus
conference and spinoff department is
just straight up one of the best cards
in the game it's literally broken
especially if you get it early on I mean
this card is literally good you know
what they all good these cards are just
amazing especially for the car strategy
but even if you're not playing the
Castro these cards are still very good
AI Central is of course also one of the
good ones especially if the game goes
long and especially if you can get it
down pretty early on the thing about AI
Central like I mentioned the first video
is it can be a little bit risky if the
game only goes to like Seventh
Generation and then you spend the entire
game playing AI Central then you could
be in trouble but for this particular
strategy yeah Central is of course very
nice so what else defines the car
strategy two you want to keep more cards
and have a bigger hand size than
normally it does happen sometimes
actually that I have 20 cards or maybe
sometimes even 30 cards in my hand
usually only two or three player games
though but if I do have all of these
cards in my hand it means that I am all
in on the greedy car strategy worth
noting you shouldn't just keep any card
you see it's not like this the character
keeps still have to be good and
preferably you'll get a lot of them for
free with capital and stuff like this
number three you create a huge engine of
money income all of the cards you're
getting are only useful to you if you
have a lot of make credit steel and
titanium production so you can actually
buy all the stuff and as you probably
know by now when I say money income this
is the stuff I mean it's all of this
stuff is good number four do not
terraform too much as you want the game
to drag out so we way back to this we
talked about in the beginning the
overall game plan for this strategy you
especially want the game to drag on for
as long as possible so you want to
identify which of the three parameters
is the last one to close and avoid
terraforming that for the most part or
if it is the second last generation and
everyone else has passed then what you
do is you terraform everything except
one step
number five get discount cards
considering that you aim to play more
Cuts than normally the secret used to
the card strategy is Discount all of
these cards here are just great if
you're going for God mode what I mean is
these types of cards is how you just
keep playing cards and keep playing
cards when you go God mode all of a
sudden you have so much Synergy that you
literally like receive Mega credits when
you play a cheap space event because you
have so much discount like Media Group
and advanced error breaking something if
you get to this point you are literally
Unstoppable this is where the card
strategy just rough also meat Industries
is really good same idea you just get
stuff and worth noting meat Industries
is closely tied to the green tag
strategy and the Green Tech strategy is
very closely related to this reality I
think so this just it just works well
together number six look for resource
amplifiers we talked about this in
Chapter 2 tip number 17 but all of these
reasons amplifies they're like perfect
especially when you go for this strategy
because you just want the biggest Indian
world has ever seen and these are the
cards together with also you should look
for these cards that gets better the
longer the game drags on once again we
talked about this in the previous video
number seven look for VP amplifiers so
of course we got the Joven amplifiers
the drawing strategy is also something
you want to look at when you're going
for this greedy card strategy naturally
and we will talk more about the German
Strat later it could also be like the
Green Tech amplifies some of these cards
here just some of them but the Green
Tech synergies in general can actually
give you even more Point than Jovian
Cuts especially when you're going guard
mode and you just play so many cats we
will also talk about this later in this
video in minus reality number six
basically these seven points here this
is what for me truly defines the greedy
card strategy and the theme Here of
course is you want to play as many cards
as possible and to play so many cards
naturally you want a strong card draw
you want Card discount you want a big
engine you want amplifiers you want
everything so with this strategy
specifically your late game VP mainly
comes from all the cards you've played
all the green tax energies all the
numbers on the cards stuff like this
Jovian amplifies microbes animals all of
this really good so like we also talked
about in the first video the formula is
money income multiplied with card draw
if these two things multiplied with each
other exceeds a thousand then you have
truly achieved god mode
and you will win I actually prepared a
clip that reflects exactly how I'm
feeling when I like one out of 100 games
managed to go full god mode I'm just
gonna run the clip actually going full
god mode is a state of mind that
encapsulates the peace and tranquility
and happiness and fulfillment you find
yourself in when you have a ton of money
and you can play a ton of cards every
single generation
to get the best effect of going full god
mode you need to have a good engine you
need to have a lot of car drawing
preferably you also need to have some
good discount cards but when you're
going full guard mode you will know
about it because it feels exactly like
this video here this is God mode
so let's break down the starting hand
because I feel like the starting hand
just screams god mode why does this
screen guard mode because I have both a
ton of card draw and a ton of Mega
credit production amplifiers and like I
said you need both so we got direct and
credit card pretty similar corporations
in this case of course a win for
director as I already have two Earth
amplifiers in my hand so the Earth tag
is worth a lot more than the no tag and
critical and also I already have a
couple of Earth tags whereas I only have
one card that costs 20 plus so of course
I'm gonna go for terractor here I would
have liked to have Point Luna instead it
would have been better but you know you
can't get everything the preloads here
are not the best to be honest they are
pretty average not nothing exciting
however two of them does come with a
science tag so I chose those two why the
science tag well because I want to play
AI Central in the first generation it's
very good and I actually can play as
intro in the first generation which is
huge this is like really why this
styling hand is so good however to do
that I still need to get the third
science tag to play Iron Central but
what we have here Olympus conference one
of the best cards in the game especially
for this strategy yeah we got this also
worth noting that the preludes even
though they're not that good they do
draw me four cards and I actually need
that because I need one more Science
Tech and I need all the Earth tags I can
get then I kept tectonic stress power
just because I needed some energy
production to play a central that's
pretty much what it is I did actually
calculate this out that I had enough
Mega credit to both play tectonic tech
power and AI Central thanks to the 60
Mega credit I got from tirector if I had
few Omega credits from my Corporation I
might have actually just bought a
standard project instead of a tectonic
stress power all of this is of course in
the service of getting AI Central in the
first generation then we've got business
Network really nice Earth tag and even
more card draw and finally I got the
mass converter which is just the cherry
on top technically I do need one more
science tag in order to play this but
with all of this card draw I have no
doubt that I'll pick up one more science
tag so just a perfect opening hand to go
God mode like I'm not kidding when I saw
this hand I immediately knew that I was
gonna win the game by having the a
double amount of points as my enemies
it's really this matters so much if you
want to you can watch this entire game
with commentary it's episode 16 part 1
and then we have another game where when
even more god mode than this one and got
278 Victory point and that is episode 16
Fatu the card strategy is the most fun
strategy to play in my opinion and it's
also like I mentioned the strategy that
can by far create the high scores yes
you can also achieve high scores with
cities and stuff but with the card
strategy this is how you can get the
really high scores and this also of
course like we talked about in the first
video is due to the fact that the cast
strategy is a stepping stone to every
other strategies except for maybe the
filthy dirt in terraforming strategy in
real life the best game I've had is 280
on generation 11 in the two-player game
with preloads Venus colonies so no
tomorrow no Fame make content and how
did I do it you guessed it I had the
greedy cast ready in that game I also
had a pretty early AI Central and I had
Byron and this combo is really good so
there's like four cards every generation
on top of that I had a god-like earth
tag opening hand with a few Earth tag
Mega credit amplifiers so this game was
just really good so like we said if you
have both card bro and money income
you go God mode and speaking of
Corporations here are a few examples of
Corporations which are quite nice when
you're going for the card strategy to be
honest there are too many good
coverations to name these are just some
example but like you probably guessed
it's all about getting money income from
your corporation and card draw if
possible a lot of people don't like Pond
Luna that much which I kind of don't
understand at least for the card
strategy this Corporation is like
perfect sometimes it just gives you a
ton of cards and the ones that's in
production is nice for engine plus the
Earth tag so if you're lucky you get
some Mega current amplifiers with Earth
tags and it it just it's awesome man but
it really also depends on number of
players I rang this build before but
like Point Luna is actually better than
two player games compared to five player
games because in five play games the
card strategy is not that good and the
next strategy here will actually compare
Point Luna to fastest good [\h__\h] let's go
minor strategy number four this city
strategy so this is a strategy that both
suits short games and can also suit long
games so this is kind kind of a special
one I'll show you what I mean so for
long games for example if you build all
the cities on the map you kind of need
time to fill up the rest of the map with
greeneries like it could be the case
that you place thesis you have immigrant
City Martian Wheels you're vibing you're
spamming cities like an absolute Maniac
covering entire planet with cities so on
the second half of the game you really
want to cover all the spaces between
your cities with greeneries otherwise
it's a big waste so in this case it
could be in your interest to let the
game drag out simply because you just
need all the time you can get to place
all the greeneries in between your
cities the key is to match the number of
cities with number of greeneries by the
end of the game if you build too many
cities while getting too few greeneries
you will lose the game so in Long games
you can actually play a mix of both the
cards reality and the city strategy and
this might be better for you so when is
it good to go over to see the strategies
in short games you can use cities and
greeneries kind of a way to close the
oxygen and the game pretty early on
perhaps it's also in your interest to
close the game as soon as possible
because to see the opponents are going
for the Ultra Mega gritty late game if
this is the case you can actually use
the city's reality in conjunction with
the terraforming strategy this could be
kind of good for you because then you
just need someone to have hit production
it could be yourself because naturally
you are going to have plant production
when you play with cities usually it's
the oxygen or the temperature that's the
last one to end the game but even if it
is the water it's actually not so bad
for you because you can just buy water
from the cards or the water standard
project and in the process you'll get a
lot more plants and also you'll get some
nice water placement bonuses and also
some nice placement bonuses for your
series and your greeneries to boot also
worth noting in short games this scores
are low which means that the VP you're
getting from your series and greeneries
could be enough for you to win the game
so what I'm really trying to say here is
that the city strategy is usually better
in four or five player games because
first of all the card strategy won't
have enough time to beat you and also in
four or five player games the opponents
are more likely to feed your three Mega
credit production by building cities all
over the map this is if you have Green
City thousands of Martian rails of
course and also like we mentioned the
city strategy plus the terraforming
strategy combo is just greater in
shorter games and usually four to five
player games are shorter in terms of
generation and then if you go to two to
three player games it's kinda exactly
the opposite which makes sense so into a
three-player games the card strategy
will likely beat you your opponents are
less likely to feed your mega credit
production by building cities on the
early game because they are fewer people
and they care more about not helping
your opponent and also the city strategy
plus terraforming strategy combo is
straight up bad in longer games it
really is the thing is in two player
games you will play to hurt your
opponent because this one opponent is
now a hundred percent of your opponents
if that makes sense this is also why
Attack cards are generally better in
two-player games and getting hit by
Attack cards actually matters a lot if
you're going for plan production which
by association also matters a lot if
you're going for cities when it comes to
burning plans itself it's actually not
so clear in this case because there are
some factors to consider here in five
player games there are more people who
can draw asteroids and also worth noting
the cards that usually burn planes are
mostly TR related cards and cards that
gives you TR a very popular in five
player games that being said the two
players in a two-player game have a lot
more cards than the 5 players and the
five player games and all I'm saying is
if you're playing two players and he
gets an asteroid then of course it will
hit you but to be clear I actually think
playing production is really good
regardless of player number in five
player games you care less about hurting
or helping an opponent because this
opponent is only 25 of your opponents so
what I'm trying to say is in five player
games you're really only playing to help
yourself it doesn't matter that much if
you're hurting one out of five opponents
it's better to help yourself that being
said if you have the opportunity of
building four plus planes from an enemy
play in a five player game you still
will of course consider it depending on
the guy you're hurting maybe it's your
rival to win the game or something and
it also depends if the asteroid you're
playing is good for you maybe there's a
bonus or something and also and this is
probably the most important part is just
very satisfying to hurt other people in
board games
in the second video in tip number 18 I
also talk a bit more about this stuff
but as you probably Gather By Now by
this insane rambling I just did it's a
bit of a gray area so many things to
consider to be honest however that being
said returning to the point I'm still
100 convinced that the city strategy is
better in four to five player games and
the city strategy is worse in two to
three player games here is an example
that really Nails how much I believe in
this statement I will go so far and this
is maybe crazy to you but I will go so
fast to say this in two player games I
think thasis is a b tier Corporation I
think Punk Luna is an issue with a girl
however in five player games I actually
think thuses is at estia with a goat and
point Luna is a beat here you might
think what are you crazy point Luna is
better than thirsty spoon is you crazy
but no I'm actually not kidding this is
I I believe in this and I should
probably Gather By Now this sort of
insane statement is tied to the fact
that I think the card strategy is better
than two player games whereas the city
strategy is better in five player games
like in four to five play games you can
actually just choose fastest and even if
you don't get any other good City
energetic cards you could just have this
Corporation anyway and just wait for
others to build some cities once in a
while and it's not terrible but of
course in most cases if you are picking
thuses it's because you yourself want to
play cities that's that's the safer way
to go and if you don't believe Luna can
be really good in two player games this
is actually the corporation I used to
get 278 on the master and like we
mentioned you can check that game out
episode 16 part 2 if like you want to
experience the full potential free
answer Dragon Ball final form of how
good point loading can be if you're
going for the car Australia final thing
I want to add to this is the Thousand
Point Luna these are never bad
corporations BT is pretty good you could
even make an argument for Asia not
important but I really hope that this
example Nails home how I actually think
about strategies and General so in my
opinion there are two ways to play the
city Strat one you go 50 all in on the
city Strat so this is better for two or
three player games maybe you didn't get
as much CD Synergy as you had hoped you
kind of want to focus on other things
also you mainly use cards to build your
engine you're playing a lot of cards
also it could happens that you just have
really good cars and you want to play
them too and this is totally fine so you
can build cities whenever it's
convenient for you and you can play
other cards whenever it's convenient for
you and finally you do need some plant
production even if you're only 50 all in
you still need a fair bit amount of
plant production so you're of course
still looking for some of these planned
amplifiers for plan production in
general of course very good when you're
going for cities and then there's the
other way of playing the city straight
which is fully overload all in so in
this case you have a lot of City
synergies the cards are kind of bad or
maybe you have so good City Synergy that
you can just focus on building cities
instead and build your wind in this way
if you have only one effect like let's
say you have immigrant City for example
and then you still consider building the
build the city standard project this is
a very desperately it's not good because
then you play 25 Mega credit for 2 Mega
credit production this is not efficient
cities are mainly a way to get VP in the
late game they're not so great for
building engine so you do need a lot of
support if you really want to go all in
and just build your engine with cities
even if you're all in full YOLO on
cities you still want to play some of
the really good Caster grid but the
capture play has to be really good I
think the mistake the people sometimes
make is that if they're going all Inland
cities then they still keep a little too
many cards than they should I'm actually
also guilty of this it's one of the
games I have on my channel you really
have to be very picky of which cards you
actually keep if you're like fully older
all in that cities and then of course
you need a lot of plant production like
if you're going all in on cities you
need all the plane production you can
get and speaking of the city and the
greenery standard project I'm not gonna
spend too much time because we talked
about this in the last video but I
thought it would still be relevant to
just mention this so when is it good to
buy the CD or the greenery as standard
projects so to start with greeneries one
you need to close the game to you want
the last few available Tia when the
parameter is about to close three you
can get the temperature bonus on the
oxygen scale four you're close to
playing a good card with oxygen
requirement and it pretty much has to be
like one of the good cards there to be
like birds insects sampling something
like this and five in the late game you
can actually use series and greeneries
to get VP it's actually quite nice it's
pretty efficient so you have to do the
math visibility to use your card so it's
better to just Spam cities and
greeneries because greeneries are mainly
three victory points sort of one Victory
point for Greenery one for oxygen and
one next to your city so what about
cities versus greeneries I've gotten
this question a few times when is it
better to actually build a city and when
is it better to build the greenery
especially in the late game as a rule
you really want to place your cities
next to at least two greeneries also be
precise when the game is over the city
actually has to be adjacent to at least
three greeneries because if it's only
next to two greeneries then it's
actually like two Mega credit more cost
effective to build the greenery next to
your city instead but then you could
also take into account that the city
gave you one Mega credit production just
know that a Greenery next to your city
that's like 2vp but if the oxygen is not
closed yet then this is better because
then it would be 3vp so the math is kind
of this if you place a Greenery next to
one of your own cities then that is two
points so usually this is better than
placing a city next to two greeneries
but maybe this city can have even more
greeneries by the end of the game so
it's really hard to say and then we have
other factors as well if the map is
filling up you should also get some of
the good City placements while you can
so because of this you can also make the
argument that it's a little bit better
to play cities first while they have a
lot of good spots for cities and then
later on you build greeneries around
your cities so cities in Greenery is are
mainly a ways to get VP which is why
these are often used in the late game
because like we alluded to cities are
pretty bad for engine building unless
you have a lot of serious energy and to
be clear you have to have like really
good City Synergy to Warrant building
this terrible City standard project in
the early game in my opinion you really
have to have two of these three cards
here why are these three cards extra
good I think well that's because they
give Mega credit production whenever a
city is placed if you play one energy to
get one gold every generation per City
that's the same as getting like
immigrant City so let's actually compare
these two guys I think people tend to
underestimate Martian rails I think this
card is actually really good I would
argue that Martian Wales is slightly
stronger than the Immigrant City but
it's kind of a close call because yes
immigrant City it gives you a city right
off the bat but then on the other hand
it gives you minus two Mega credit
production to play and then you get one
bag so it's really like one Mega credit
production minus and both of these cards
kinda cost one energy production when
you think about it and both of these
cards kinda gives you one Mega credit
production inside the city's place so
they're really similar but there are
small differences though the advantages
of Martian Wheels is that the gifts you
make a credit in the same generation as
you play it so that's like slightly
better than just getting passive make a
credit production on the flip side Then
You're vulnerable to cards that steal
your energy production but they're only
two of those and that doesn't happen
that often the small advantage of
immigrant City however is that it also
works on off-world cities margin rails
and cebulins they do not work on
off-world cities and the mega credit
production aspect are fastest step does
not work on awful cities either let's
talk about immigrant City because this
card is actually pretty well it can
sometimes sit straight up win you the
game and sometimes it actually loses you
the game without you even knowing about
it so the trick is to actually
understand when exactly to use this car
the thing is it actually takes a while
for immigrant City to kick in and you
can't know if your opponent will help
you build cities after you play
Immigrant City and in a game that's all
about this snowballed effect you have to
be really careful when you're spending
this much like 13 Mega credits three for
the cards and an energy production for
something that essentially gives you
minus Mega credit production however
down the road immigrant City can give
you so much I have no doubt that it's a
good card but you really have to be
careful here so when exactly should you
play this card first of all you need to
play it at the start of the generation
if this is the generation you decide to
play Immigrant City play it as soon as
possible because usually people tend to
start the generation building cities so
getting immigrant City down as soon as
possible is pretty key and also if you
plan on playing immigrant City you kind
of need to have a plan to build more
cities yourself you can't just rely on
other people building cities and pumping
this up for you oh can you maybe you
could because maybe you have a read that
someone else is about to build a city
maybe they are playing thuses or maybe
you play draft and you pass along some
good City casts like research outposts
or something or maybe just predict that
people are about to compete for the Mia
Milestone so if you have a read like
this then it would be entirely
reasonable to just slam down immigrant
City so like I said if you play against
thuses and you just play Immigrant City
well now you also fastest with one
cartridges completely canceled out the
bonus of his Corporation that's a little
bit funny when that happens and finally
you can also just play Immigrant City
and just like hope you get lucky but I
mean this is really risky okay I'm not
so sure this is a good idea then we got
other cities in agility cards like these
these accounts that are definitely
casually looking for when you're playing
cities but for the purposes of engine
building these by themselves are not
really enough and if you really want to
play this trash standard project in the
early game then you kind of need to have
two of The Big Three like immigrant City
Marching real fastest then you might be
thinking why is sibling not up there
that also gives a mega credit production
based on cities but the thing is the
five oxygen requirement and siblings
just makes this card so unreliable
sometimes it takes a long time for the
oxygen to even go there and by that time
then the mega credit production you get
is not really that much of a big deal
because maybe we're already in the mid
to late game where zebulance truly shine
is when you just top dig it in the early
to mid game where the oxygen is close to
five and then you can maybe even just
build a Greenery just to get this down
and it feels really good however the
biggest issue with this card in my
opinion is that you cannot keep it in
your opening hand because it's just too
unreliable so you kind of just have to
hope that you Chopstick this card at the
right time and if you do that it can be
very strong it's very awkward to keep
this in your opening hand because you
just never know how much time it will
take before the five oxygen requirement
has been met but what if you don't have
immigrant City margin rails or fastest
or maybe you just have one of these
calves what is your plan then let's say
for instance you picked up a card like
pets so pets doesn't really give you any
Mega credit production or make a credits
or anything it's only a card to get VP
and normally a ring this bill that VP
should be played in the second half of
the game or the end of the game or
something like this but this is kind of
different right because this card gives
a lot of VP during the game it actually
gives more VP the earlier you put it
down so this is one of these luxury
cards as I see it that you can play in
the early game if your economy can
handle it and if your economy is still
struggling you kind of want to get your
engine building cards down first in that
case you can still play it in the mid
game and it's still gonna be fine I
think the mistake that some players make
is oh I get I get pitched down as soon
as possible in the first generation and
it's not that important to get it down
that early what I'm saying is that it
might actually ruin your chances of
building an efficient engine if you just
play cars like these in the first first
generation it's okay to wait until the
mid game before you play a card like
that and you might be thinking oh but
I'm missing out on free VP nah but what
you're getting in return is like 10 mega
credits you could have spent an engine
so it's it's like a trade-off you have
to make the assessment it's more
important for me to make a good engine
here and now it's more important to just
land armpits however needless to say is
anyone around the table is going for
cities you are going to play pets pets
is a stupidly strong card or you could
just play it because you're sitting with
like Miranda Resort and you need the
Earth Tech or something immigration
shuttles is also a card that I should
mention here at the end of the game it
gives you like one VP per three cities
placed so if you get like 12 or 15
cities that is kind of good because then
it'll give three or four victory points
at the end of the game it also depends
when you can play it it's one of these
cards well if if I don't really have
anything to build my engine with I might
as well take this one but it's not
efficient because 31 for 5 Mega credit
production it's a very slow way to build
your engine but if you have nothing
better and you are going for cities then
why not this card feels to me a little
bit like a sort of a Joven amplifier if
you're going for cities but by the end
of the game there really should be like
12 or 15 cities on the map for this card
to be worth it I think and it doesn't
have to be only your cities it can also
be everyone else's cities road
construction is another car that's just
so cheap and so good that you just play
if anyone is going for cities you just
play Rover construction it's really
cheap it comes from the VP and you don't
have to place a lot of cities for this
car to to just pay for itself so I think
this car is really good also a thing to
keep in mind is everyone including
myself we all are we have to get mega
credit production and stuff like this
but getting to make a creative service
every time you see this place it's
pretty good as well like if you think
about it if there are only two
generations left in the game then this
card Rover construction it's like better
than actually getting one Mega credit
production so it's also a little bit
about when you play it but this card is
so cheap it's like pits is one of these
luxury cards I'll just lay it whenever I
have the opportunity and naturally if
you are planning to peel cities yourself
of course it would be nice if you could
play Rover construction before start
building your cities stand on projects
kind of the same thing if you're going
for the Silver City Center project this
is really good especially for the late
game when you're building a lot of these
I feel like I've talked plainly about
similar technology it's a good car
greenhouses is a deceptively strong car
if you think about it if you only have
like eight cities on the map then you
can get a Greenery down for six Mega
credit if I'm fastest I might even keep
this in my opening hand just so I can
play it in the late game this card is
like really strong in the last
generation or you can also use this card
to get the temperature bonus on the
oxygen scale make a play like this it's
also fine but mostly I think I would
play this in the last generation it's a
perfect cuts if you're all in on City
and then you slam this in the last
generation you'll get like two or three
green Aries that you could just put in
between your cities now a few things to
keep in mind when you're playing the
city strategy sooner or later all
players should build at least one city
it doesn't matter if you're going for
the city shred or not no matter what
Strat you're going for really you should
have one city placed on the map at some
point in the game and the reason this is
useful information is that if you are
like claiming all the good City spots on
the map let's say you have fastest and
immigrant City and stuff like this like
if you're really lucky and you just
can't get away with like building a lot
of cities and building your engine this
way in that case you're kind of forcing
people to sooner or later get one of the
good last available CD spots and people
might even start to panic a little bit
because they can see oh [\h__\h] I have to
get at least one of the good available
spots left and this could be kind of
nice because then they're feeding your
free Mega credit production and
additionally maybe they feel forced to
place down a city sooner than they would
have liked instead of going for their
own plan they kind of feel oh [\h__\h] I
have to get one city that's like five
greeneries around it or something so
you're a little bit disrupting their
plants maybe but that being said is also
a little bit of a double-edged sword
because when you're playing this Golden
City stress and you'll see this all over
you kind of don't want an enemy City in
the middle of your Empire so placing
your city strategically is to avoid
people just grieving you with a city in
the middle of your Empire that's also
helping you have to think about now you
need to know when to stop spamming
cities like I mentioned this is like
literally the hardest thing about
playing the city strategy is knowing
when to stop if you're building too few
cities then your engine might not be
good enough and you're not getting all
the good City spots but then again if
you're building too many cities then you
won't have time enough to build
greeneries around your cities there's
also this aspect of it being a little
bit of an illusion you always think you
made the wrong choice but maybe you
really didn't maybe it's just because
your opponents are reacting to the fact
that they're like all right he's making
more cities now we have to close the
game so the game could just be over
sooner than you predicted and it's also
the thing like if you're building cities
having a good time you're building a
bunch of series getting Mega credit
production this is fun man this is
really fun it's like you have to force
yourself stop having fun because you
need to force yourself to be a
responsible adult not placing cities all
over the map sometimes you just need to
stop a little earlier even though it's a
lot of fun you just have to stop a
little early and start building
greeneries around your cities otherwise
you're gonna lose that's all I'm saying
but maybe it's not about winning maybe
it's about having fun putting cities
everywhere as I'm sure you know by now
VP comes from greeneries around your
cities the cities themselves does not
give any VP so you have to make
greeneries around the city to actually
score some VP at the end of the game if
you get no greeneries you get no VP from
your cities because the city strategy
really goes hand in hand with plan
production I think most people know this
but I don't think people realize that if
you get like a lot of playing production
let's say you get killed farming with
ecology research Prelude or you get some
some sort of insane plant production
going then you really should do the city
Strat to some extent you really should
place a lot of cities so you can take
all the greeneries down and that's
probably going to be enough for you to
win the game so the city straight can be
if you're fastest or something but the
city Strat can also come with your eco
line or you get like a lot of plant
production somewhere these two things
are linked together playing production
City Strat these two are like two half
of the same coin if that makes sense now
let's look at another insane starting
hand ahead once again if you want to
watch the full game it's episode 18 part
one this hand just screams going for
cities I mean going all in on cities
this hand is really good let's talk
about why then we got exactly the combo
I said before I think I got the name
wrong but on what I'm talking about is
ecology experts and kelp farming this
combo is insane so look what you're
getting with this combo you're getting
two make a creative production two plans
and four plan production and a victory
part and two plane tags which can also
be really good because I have M6 here so
the other Prelude here is uh pretty bad
I mean the funny thing is that even with
this golden starting hand I got I'm
going for cities I'm going for plant
production even then this early
settlement still feels like a bad
pre-look cut I I don't know man this
card is really bad but if there was ever
a game where I really should try to make
this early settlement Prelude work it
should be now right the funny thing is
even with this Golden City starting hand
I might actually have made a mistake not
taking donation over early settlement
the argument for donation here is that
I'm starting with i o mining Industries
so there's an argument to be made that
you play donation and then you're like
in the second generation maybe you can
play Iron mining Industries in this case
and speaking of iron mining Industries
I'm not sure I should have kept this
card I mean it's it's so tempting right
get higher money Industries in your
opening hand oh man it feels good and if
you're gonna watch the game like in
hindsight I know that this was a bad
call because I ended up having only one
Jovian and that was I am any Industries
and in that case it's just simply not
worth it also keep in mind that this is
a four player game so the game is going
to be over pretty soon so all things
considered I don't think it should have
kept IO mining Industries even though it
hurts my heart but I really don't think
I should have kept this guy I needed to
just have enough discipline to just say
all right I'm going all in on cities
that's all I'm gonna do it's gonna be
plenty enough to win the game no problem
I don't need iron Industries it's kind
of not the threat I'm going for that's
what I should have done but it's really
hard
to just not keep iron mining Industries
in your opening hand I'm sure you guys
can relate then we got bright committee
one of these well I think this card is
okay it gives like two Mega critic
production for 10 mega credits so it's
kinda on the weak side but I think the
play here would have been to keep right
committee and then throw away iron
mining Industries I think that's what I
should have done that would have been
better and then we also got Development
Center I could have kept this if I kept
the power generation it would have been
all right but then I'm not getting the
plan production in the city and you know
my my strategy is kind of all in them
cities so I really have to be picky
which cards do I keep and when do I just
go all in on cities then we got worms
for once I actually kept this card but
that's because I have three micro
attacks already and it's also worth
noting that worms and insects they have
a high oxygen requirement but I have so
much Plan production in this hand
there's gonna be no problem for me to
raise the oxygen so I can actually play
these cards there we go robotic
Workforce also a card I maybe shouldn't
have kept it's a little bit greedy but I
think my idea was that I could use this
on early settlement so at the very least
I can get one plant production with this
card so in that case it's like adaptive
Legion but without the plant tag so that
actually sounds really bad when I say it
out loud so even though I get a really
good starting hand like this there's
still a lot of things you have to
consider but that being said when I see
the starting hand I have no doubt that
I'm gonna win the game and once again
especially considering that this is a
four player game the card's reality is
not gonna beat me because the game is
gonna probably be short so I'm feeling
very confident this this is a very good
start again for going for cities a
little bonus with the city Strat is that
a lot of Milestone and awards actually
fits with the city strategy so if we got
the vanilla map here then we have Maya
Gardner and landlord so these are two
milestones and what award that caters to
this landlocked this is why the city
strategy is a Little Bit Stronger on the
vanilla map here three cities easy three
Gap easy landlord obviously but on the
other Maps they usually are like two
things that caters to the city strategy
so here on the Hillis map we got the
polar Explorer I mean you can start the
game by making a few cities down there
if you want you can also play it further
north to get some of the good plans but
this is something to keep in mind also
the cultivator like I said the city
strategy goes hand in hand with plants
so it makes a lot of sense to also go
for the cultivator and on Elysium kind
of the same story we got this Etc and we
got a state dealer it's a little bit
awkward that the desert settler wants
you to play cities in the South and the
estate dealer wants you to play cities
in the north but you know if you're
going all in the cities you're probably
a cities everywhere so it's kind of good
also a little bonus if you're playing
thuses on this map is that there is this
Olympus moons which has three cards so
no matter what I do if I place asses I
would always put a city there I think
and then you might be thinking but then
you're only getting like maybe two
plants around that City and yeah that's
kind of true but I think I would still
take the three cups to be honest it's
just too good to pass up there's also a
spot with three plans also worth noting
that's also really good how to counter
the city strategy so what do you do if
the opponent is playing the series
strategy there's a few things you can do
it's actually not that hard to counter
you can play City synergetic cards
yourself if you're playing against
fastest or something just display pets
just play Immigrant City the thing about
City synergetic cards is that they work
when opponents are building cities so
even though you're not planning to build
so many cities yourself if you're
playing against fastest just slam down
beds or something and then he will just
keep giving you a lot of stuff during
the game you don't even have to do
anything so if you play like immigrant
City you're completely canceling out the
effect of his cooperation because now if
he wants to build City then he's gonna
give gold to himself and you also you
can just place a bunch of annoying tile
in the middle of his Empire so this way
to count up the city Strat is also
pretty straightforward just consider
keeping cast that has a placement bonus
and just use it to disrupt his little
pattern and just put it in the middle of
his Empire he's gonna be so salty about
it and you can even do this in the late
game so in the late game if you pick up
like for free maybe a card like mining
area or industrial center then these
cards they're pretty bad at this point
but you can still use them to just be a
little terrorist so you're kind of
playing these cards as if they were
Attack cards they don't really do
anything for you not in the late game
but you can just play them because
they're cheap and they're gonna like
they him a couple of points it's really
annoying number three just build a total
of one to two cities and I'm talking
about just during the game at some point
you don't have to do it at the start of
the game in that case you're just gonna
give him make a credit production the
thing is you always want to have at
least one city on the map and the reason
you put it in the middle of his Empire
is first of all to disrupt his plan is
gonna be really annoying for him you're
gonna deny him a lot of points and if
you manage to put it like smack in the
middle of his Empire then he's probably
gonna have to like at least Place some
greeneries around your city because it's
also helping himself right so you're
gonna get a little bit of extra value
for free this way and finally you can
just forget about him and just focus on
your own game the thing is I think
people are maybe hyping up fastest a
little bit too much like it's not that
strong I mean you can just focus on your
own game and maybe you'll beat him just
by playing cards or playing your own
strategy you really don't have to play
his game if that makes sense this
chapter ended up being a little bit long
so I thought it was just here at the end
I would just give a little bit of
summation of what we have learned in
this chapter so one you got a lot of
cities energetic cards obviously then
you are inclined to go for cities
immigrant City Martian rails fastest
these are probably the strongest one but
there's a lot of good cars for senior
cited yet so if you get some of these
cars or some of the other cars I'm not
mentioning here sure go for it and two
if you've got a lot of plant production
you should really consider going to city
so these are some of the planned
amplifiers if you get some of this stuff
see this is definitely on the menu you
are in a four or five player game like
we talked about I'm pretty confident
that the city strategy in general is
stronger in four or five player games
and you can also play it in two three
player games but then it should be like
half City straight and half cut strategy
especially in two player game you just
have to go for the card strategy and
then if you're also on top of that get
some City Jetta cards perfect you can do
both that being said if your entire hand
just screams it is it's still fine right
just know that it comes with a lot more
risk and two or three player games and
finally you play on the stand-up map
with Maya Garden landlord then the
city's red is a little bit extra good
and that's pretty much it for this
episode it went a little bit longer than
I thought so I'm gonna cut this in two
so in the second half we're gonna talk
about Joby Intex and green tags so thank
you so much for watching as always if
you have anything you want to debate
with me in Australia might have been
missing here or something feel free to
mention in the comments thanks for
watching